police storming niece's notre dame
basilica were too late to stop the
bloodshed
by the time they shot and injured the
attacker three people had been fatally
wounded
one of them was a church official
we've just learned from the television
that our sacristan has been assassinated
it's a huge shock
he was there all day long he wasn't
somebody who would drop in
and go again he was always there
the church is just a kilometer from the
scene of a deadly truck attack which
killed dozens in 2016.
niece's mayor spoke to reporters at the
scene he said the assailant kept
shouting allahu akbar or god is greatest
as he was detained
to all the people of nice who are in
shock
i can say that nice like all of france
but perhaps more than other parts of the
country
is currently paying much too higher
price and has now once more
become a victim of islamofascism
it's the threat that has france on high
alert president macron called a crisis
meeting in paris before departing for
nice
the french president has angered many in
the muslim world
by refusing to condemn cartoons of the
prophet muhammad
[Music]
it's a long-standing debate in france
reignited by the murder of school
teacher samuel patti earlier this month
he was beheaded after showing cartoons
of muhammad in a class on free speech
now france has three more reasons to
mourn
the national assembly held a minute
silence for the victims
those in power face some uncomfortable
questions in the days ahead
many in this strictly secular country
may ask if the official approach is the
right one
and whether they should fear more lone
wolf attacks
authorities have raised the terror alert
level to its maximum
let's get you more now where catherine
field is a reporter
in paris catherine has any
more information been released by the
authorities
we know pretty much the timeline of what
happened this morning
it was just before nine o'clock in the
morning
when the church warden opened the church
up he does it every morning
he's aged in his 40s he opens it up says
people can go in there and pray there
isn't a morning mass
at this basilica uh then the attacker
came into the church
he stabbed the man uh he also then
stabbed a parishioner a woman aged in
her 70s
he then chased one of the parishioners
out of the church
and in a nearby bar he stabbed her as
well to death a woman aged in her 30s
it was then the police came on the scene
they shot
the attacker wounded him and we're told
by the mayor of nice that when he was
receiving treatment from
from first responders he was calling out
allah
since then we know that this has been
handed over to the anti-terror
police the the investigations branch
there and they will be following this
and trying to piece together what it has
in common with other
similar attacks we've had three jihadist
attacks in the last month
do we know anything about the motive why
now
why nice
no we unfortunately we don't know
anymore i mean this is coming up to an
important day for the catholic faith it
is all saints
day it is a national holiday here in
france
of course there is this continuing
dispute
with france over the publication behind
charlie hebdo
of these cartoons of the prophet
muhammad let's not forget
that here in paris at the moment there
is the court case going on
for the accomplices of that 2015 attack
on the offices of charlie hebdo so
that's caused
a lot more of a of a focus to be on
those cartoons
also there has been negative reaction
from outside france
to remarks made by the french president
saying that france will defend
its freedom of expression and as he said
at the memorial service to the slain
school teacher
he said france will continue to publish
these cartoons
all right catherine field uh reporting
from paris so thank you so much
and i'd like to turn now to
a counterterrorism advisor and security
expert and ceo
of mosaicon uh thank you so much for
joining us
uh sir um why does
this keep happening in france this is a
shocking attack that just happened what
like a week
after the samurai attacked the the
the brutal murder of the french teacher
in the outskirts of paris
did authorities not expect another
attack a copy
cat attack did they really drop the ball
here
um it's it's a good question but we we
have to see it from from two levels the
the first one is
um overall uh these attacks
and the planned attacks uh have occurred
a lot in the uk this year in france in
various areas so
although we get the impression
especially of late that france appears
to be singled out
um it actually fits a broader pattern
in europe as a whole where these attacks
keep
occurring however france as your
reporter
accurately mentioned over the last two
months
has put itself right in the middle due
to
yes the charlie hebdo trial uh the
republication of the caricatures that
originally led to the attack in 2015
uh then the macrons positions
and the following reaction so
france very recently put itself even
more in the middle of the storm and it
doesn't mean that the security forces
dropped the ball here but
uh with the added issues related to the
pandemic over the last eight months
we've seen a rise
in extremist uh online content we've
seen our eyes far right far left right
and all these elements together create
that problem
um i'm gonna jump in here i'm gonna jump
in here if i may
you reference that these uh attacks do
happen across europe and you have a
point there
we have seen sadly across europe uh
terror attacks in the
uh in the previous years but there is a
deadly pattern
that is specific to france that we see
unfolding
how should government you're an anti a
counterterrorism expert how should the
government tackle this kind of
threat coming now from individuals not
non-state actors these are just
individuals
who decide we're going to go out and
kill someone
what can be done to prevent another
attack from happening in a week's time
that's the the best question and and
it's trying to find a way to isolate
these people and and what i mean by that
is
um they they find you know we we see
them
acting a lot so so alone so perpetrating
the attack alone
however they're not alone there's a lot
there's an echo chamber whether it be
online or
is closer knit communities where they
find a way to uh
amplify and catalyze their their
positions to a point where
it becomes violent and what we need to
the focus needs to be more on the the
preventive aspect so that
all the aspects leading up to the attack
itself
can communities find a way and security
forces as well to
isolate where it really becomes an
exception and no longer a norm and
what's very interesting with the attack
today in france is that
right away uh two major muslim
organizations
one of them who was actually disbanded
yesterday
vocally said we don't agree with this uh
we think it's it's not right
so if the narrative changes if the
if if security forces governments find a
way to change a narrative
in in a preventive way uh to ensure that
these extremists become more isolated
within
within their bubble uh then we'll have a
reduction and it
yeah it's about it we won't prevent it a
hundred percent but if we can
make it exceptional again that will
already be a major achievement
in conclusion though and this might be a
little bit controversial
there is a tendency in the french
political discourse to target muslims
in a very antagonistic way or make
muslims french muslims feel very
defensive
so if you want the help of the community
should the rhetoric change
in france should mr macron also adjust
and reach out
to the community so that the community
feels compelled
and feels part of the french society and
will raise more red flags
when they see individuals planning on
doing such things
i i agree france's history doesn't
help it um and you know there's a lot of
the
there's a lot of support from the
community already you know and a lot of
the one of the things that's come out in
in
other attacks is you know the community
will have actually said to
uh you know people responsible hey
please you know you should watch that
person and then still the attack happens
so
there's a certain degree of support but
of course france being reluctant until
until macron to be honest to look into
its colonial past to actually
acknowledge
uh the problems in algeria for example
the way its muslim community in france
is being treated
is a major issue and uh and it's gonna
take a long time we are indeed talking
about a generational issue so it's not
something that's going to be solved
within two or three years but it's going
to take a long time and i i
fully agree uh that the overall
narrative
and and the with the muslim community in
france due to historical reasons
needs to change and need to become more
compromising and inclusive
because as we're seeing a lot of people
are willing to act even if they're not
part of a broader structure
a counterterrorism advisor and security
expert thank you
for making time to speak to us